hello everyone and welcome to Game four
of the 1971 semi final candidates match
between bent Larsen and the Bobby
Fischer now as I haven't uploaded for
quite a while one whole day let's just
figure out what happened in this series
so first we covered the 1970 palma de
mallorca tournament which Bobby Fischer
really where he obliterated the field
then we continued with the Bobby Fischer
vs. marked the man of match where he
well did kind of crush mark came out of
6 to 0 but if you haven't seen the games
then you know that it's not like he just
came in cross mark de mano he really put
up a very strong resistance and then now
we are covering the bent Larsen versus
Bobby Fischer this is game number four
we've already checked out game 1 2 & 3
game 1 started with that beautiful rope
captures an e5 move if you are new to
this channel perhaps then do check out
all of the other videos as well from the
series I will put the links to the three
games between Larsen in the description
below the first three things you will
see will be the links so saying that
let's check out this game now we do have
a photo of this event as we already
mentioned in video 1 from the dis match
I was play played in a temple built
college in Denver Colorado so there we
have it a photo from Game one now let's
check out sorry about that let's check
out this game Fisher Fisher has the
black pieces and the Larson opens with
c4 so although we have English Bobby
replies with his standard first four
moves that Hughes's against well not
always but against c4 d4 Knight f3 he he
often uses these first four moves g6
Knight of three Bishop g7 d4 Knight f6
Knight c3 and we have castles here we
have the Kings Indian defense on the
board
efore d6 and now comes the rush of 2 e 2
e 5 this is the standard variation we
have castles knights to c6 and d5 9 3 7
we have 9th to d2 and c5 here c5 a very
nice idea by Fischer although at the
time this was played
it was thought to be a bit of a reckless
move because it kind of doesn't go by
the go by the principles if you play the
Kings Indian defense you know that white
will come at you on the queenside then
of course you want to play on the Kings
side you want to get your Knights out of
the way pull the pawns and checkmate the
white king and it's kind of against the
principles to push up on a side pawn on
the side of the board where you are
weaker but okay Fischer somehow as
you'll see makes it work he was for c5
if Knight to d7 for example instead of
c5 if 97 then before and after f5 comes
c5 and this seems somewhat better for
white oh ok Fischer goes c5 and here we
have rook to be one capturing this am
Pathan doesn't really achieve anything
it only strengthens black center and it
weakens white so here rook to be one was
played it's very interesting because in
1961 a game between polar bears came
drink was played in Belgrade where
instead of rook to b1 a3 was played and
the game continued pretty much the same
as this game Larsen versus Fischer 98
was played before b6 rook to b1 we have
f5 and here a a for Knight to f6 and a5
so this is the position from the game
blue graph is K versus drink from 1969
but this is also the position from the
game Larsen versus Fischer the one that
we are covering only difference is here
in this position after c5 a Larson went
immediately looked to be one and this
eventually won him the tempo this game
continued knife to e8 always a useful
square for the knight in the Kings
Indian defense B 4 B 6 a 4 f5 now we
have a 5 Knight to f6 and now it's
White's move and in the previous
position that we've shown the position
is exactly the same only it's blacks
move to play so you know after 2 years
an improvement in this position has been
made and now white wins the tempo so
here Larsson goes Queen to a4 Queen to a
forward ideas of a captures and b6
so you do have to do something about
this as he increased the pressure on the
Queen side butter up to this
Fisher attack slower since Queen Queen
to a3 and now comes butcher to h6
already this is a move 15 a Larsson is
about to make his 16th move and well we
could say that this is a position where
a turning point will occur here Bishop
to d3 was played by Larsen as you can
see if Fisher is kind of threatening to
capture the knight on D to remove one of
the defenders of the e4 pawn but here
later it was found that Larsen should
have went for B captures on c5 and after
B captures on c5 not push a 6 you know
say to Fischer you can have the pawn but
I'm continuing with what I started I'm
gonna continue playing on the Queen side
and I will play for activity here and
then after Bishop captures the Bishop
captures and Knight captures on e4
Fischer would win a pawn here F captures
on e4 but then after Bishop to g5 you
can see that white simply has so much
activity here
Queen is coming to e3 this rook can come
to b7 a very nice position for white but
probably due to the fact that Larsson
did lose the first three games he said
okay maybe not to give up material maybe
maybe you know material is better than
activity but who knows Bishop to d3
protecting the pawn and now Queen to c7
big captures on c5 b captors on c5 and
now okay now this did happen but now a6
isn't really all that impressive Fischer
can simply you know block Larsen's rook
with rook to b8 so be captures on c5 and
now he captures an f5 by Larsson G
captures on f5 and now comes Bishop the
c2 also possible and something that was
discussed during the game I was nice to
b5 simply forcing black to capture here
because you don't really have a good
reply to this other than capturing the
night and this Bishop is a pretty strong
piece you know because the d6 pawn is
under attack you're under attack there's
no good Square for the Queen
other than b8 to keep protecting this
point and now you're simply aligning
your queen with with the rook here and
you know you're stifling the development
of the rook on a8 but okay after Knight
b5 Bishop captures on b5 would be played
and here white would have the opportune
video playing row captor zombie five or
perhaps even deciding to sacrifice upon
by connecting these pawns but then
giving up at this bone but after 94 it
would you know prove to be a very
interesting game but okay after G
captors on f5 Bishop to c2 was played
and now comes the case a 6 as Larson
failed to push a 6 himself now Fischer
does it preventing Larson from ever
pushing gay sex in himself and also
keeping an eye on this very important be
5 square Knight d2 e for a Larson opens
up an attack against Fischer's bishop on
h6 and also threatening Knight captures
on f6 with Czech Bishop captures unsee
one we're gonna attack on the Queen
Knight captures on f6 with Czech rook
captures on f6 and now rook captures on
C 1 we have rook a to f8 and the now
comes rock to b6 a very nice active move
by Larson but even with such an active
move the rook will be somewhat too
displaced here as you'll see in the game
Fischer goes Bishop deceive c8 makes
room for the Queen to enter the game
we have Knight to e2 and then out comes
F for preventing Larson from you know
improving the position of his Knight
we have Bishop to e4 and now comes
Knight to f5 rook the c6 attacking
Fischer's queen Fischer goes Queen to g7
and this is again kind of a important
moment in the game as you can see this
is a very active room but the rook isn't
really doing all that much here in the
game the rook to be one was played by
Larson getting preparing drugs to come
also crashing down either to the eighth
rank or order the 6th rank but King to
h1 as you'll see in the game would have
been much better as it it would allow
this work to come to g1 and help out
with the defense here rook to be one was
played and now comes Knight to h4 night
to h4 pressuring the the Jie du Pont
okay so at the moment this Bishop is
guarding in the g2 pawn but this Bishop
is coming to f5 the threat and the
exchange and of course win captures and
g2 will be the threat and now you see if
King to h1 was played on the previous
move here rook to g1 would actually be
an excellent and excellent defense here
we have Queen to d3
this was played in the game but it's
very interesting when Fischer played
this night cat night to h4 move he also
had to calculate what happens if rook
captures on c8 and this is a very
important line because ok it seems like
rook captures and Queen to h3 comes with
a double attack the rope is under
attacked and also the night here but it
doesn't work because if you are
persistent here after rook to f8 and you
captured the night rook to h6 will trap
Larsen's Queen so a white would be lost
here
so after night h4 yeah Larsson saw that
rook captures and see it doesn't work he
went Queen to d3 guarding in you know
giving further protection to DF v square
a but it doesn't matter Bishop f5 Nanda
lies by Fisher again you can't capture
here because you're still gonna be
checkmated on g2 after Bishop to a5 King
to h1 was played f3
now of course continuing the attack and
also blocking bishops defense of the G
to square again the threat is Queen
captures on g2 United to g3 and now F
captures on g2 with check you don't
really have the option of capturing if
you capture them simply you lose the
Queen so after F characters in g2 pink
the g1 was played and now comes the
shock captures on e4 Queen captures on
e4 and now comes Knight to f3 trick
there are no options here for white you
can either capture the night which is a
bit silly as the knight is protected or
you can play King captures and g2 which
was played in the game but here fish are
simply play tonight to d2 would an
attack on Larsen's Queen wouldn't attack
on Larsen's rook can be won also the
double rooks are threatening to come
crashing down on f2 so there is really
nothing for what you do here whatever
you play Fischer will simply pick up the
rook play rook captures on f2 and it's a
completely lost position for Larsson
so here I'll move 33 after Fischer's
night to d2 bent Larsen resigned the
game and the result is now four to zero
in Fisher's favor so it's very
interesting after this game Larsen said
that he was ill and you know the match
was postponed not the match game fight
was postponed until Larsen starts
feeling better and
they didn't say while Larson was feeling
ill or what what was actually wrong with
him but there were some mentions that
due to the sea level of the city you
know or something like that he that he
didn't feel all that great but he will
of course recover and this match will
continue and so we with the series so I
do hope you enjoyed this game Larson
definitely didn't end you can see if you
follow the the series so far you can see
that in Game one especially but also in
Game two
Larson really really played excellent
chess but then even as he himself will
say later his performance simply dropped
as he can be felt in this game you don't
simply lose the game in 30 moves you
know when you're playing the candidates
match so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you're enjoying the
the entire Bobby Fischer series so far
like I said if you're new to the channel
or maybe haven't seen all of the games
in the series and you are interested in
Bobby Fischer do check out some
interesting links in the description
below and like I said I haven't uploaded
in some time so there are plenty of you
who have contributed to my channel
so I would like to thank all of you and
as I don't have room for all of you here
in on the screen I will oops
I will thank you this way and also I
will add all of your names into the
description of the video and I will also
thank you in a couple of other videos as
well as there are simply too many of you
so I would like to thank Donna platform
it's a better floor Daniel Larson
Christopher lotteries Prabhakar Krishna
Travis twig stead an index NL bv Gregory
mole F Monique Castile guy Phillips
Christopher Amash Matthew Bell Gil
Theresa Alina pseudo is Danny McCullough
Robin Vere Cody Travis Muhammad his
Hamal Warren Beck and Nicholas tiba and
Ray Fowler with his contribution rate
Fowler has also became also became the
top contributor to this channel ending
Sean Wilcox and he'll long reign ever
since Christmas last year I believe
so very very glad to see that you are
still enjoying the content ray so that's
it for this video like I said I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank all
for watching and I will see you soon
most likely with Game five of the 1971
semi final candidates match between
Bobby Fischer and bent Larsen thank you
all and I'll see you soon